Good morning Hank. It's Tuesday.
I landed in Venice, Italy yesterday morning feeling a smidge tired
and then stood in this very long customs line
before catching a ride into the city.
Are we gonna see some Palazzos?
SARAH : If we want to.
What about some statuettos?
Are you-a gonna be annoyed if this whole trip I'm just gonna
add a vowel to the end of a noun.
SARAH : Yes
Is that gonna offend you?
SARAH : It is.
Okay... well.
I'll bear that in mind-o.
We're in Venice to film this huge art show called the
The Venice Biennale for the Art Assignment,
Sarah's show with PBS, but our filming didn't start until tomorrow
So we checked into our hotel room,
Marveled at the view,
And then set out into the city.
Venice is a very crowded city, but not with residents.
It's population has shrunk by more than half in the last forty years.
In fact, more people lived in Venice a thousand years ago,
than do so today.
But visitors still arrive in droves to see the great floating city,
Its' narrow alleys,
Its' gondolas,
And its' famed art and architecture.
It's so picturesque it often doesn't seem real,
And I guess in some ways it isn't.
I mean in the eighteenth century there were more than eight thousand gondolas in Venice
and they were the primary means of transportation.
Today, there are about four hundred, and they're used almost exclusively by tourists
Then again you can't really complain about crowds of tourists
When you are, you know, part of that crowd
So first we made our way past the Fenice Theater,
down a series of winding alley ways ,
to the Libreria Alta Acqua
This sprawling canal-side bookstore with towers of books pressing in on all sides.
Outside books that have decayed past the point of readability formed
a kind of sculpture. A reminder I guess of where all books are going.
And also all cities.
But there's no to despair about such inevitabilitys because there's gelatto!
I got tiramisu and chocolate and it was amazing!
We stopped at the top of the bridge over the grand canal to marvel at the view
And then made our way to the Peggy Guggenheim collection.
Where we saw an Anish Kapoor sculpture, and this Sarah-ish Modigliani
And art by Warhol and Frank Stella
and Picasso and Jackson Pollock but mostly I saw the
backs of people's heads because it was really crowded.
So we made our way back outside and sat for a while on this bridge
watching the Gondolas come and go. It was
ridiculously beautiful and the sun felt good on my face and I
started thinking about the last time I was in Venice, just
over six years ago. My video that day began "I'm in Venice, and I'm really sick"
I was in fact, very very sick
The next day I had to cut my visit short and fly back to Amsterdam,
it turned out that my gallbladder needed removing. But in
addition to the physical illness, my mental health was
near an all time low. And now, six years later, Sarah
and I were walking toward the Piazza San Marco,
where I'd filmed that video. It's the tourist capital of Venice, and also
the pigeon capital and back in 2011,
I hated it. I remembered it smelling of death, and decay
and I hated the tourists and the pigeons and
the stupid flying lions everywhere and I was so sick
and so scared, and it sucked!
But yesterday afternoon, I was happy in the Piazza San Marco
Which has been a gathering place for humans for nearly a millennium.
I loved watching
families from all over the world,
I loved watching people take selfies with history, God help me,
I didn't even mind the pigeons! And I was reminded that how you feel
at your worst is not how you're always going to feel. I mean, sure
the world is going to end, and Venice
will sink into the sea.
But not yet.  Sitting in the Piazza drinking
unconscionably expensive espresso, I was reminded that
the world is what it is, but the world is also
what you bring to it, and who you share it with.
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.